what InnoCentive does is we've got a
network today of almost 180,000 what we
call solvers from around the world 200
plus countries sixty percent of them
have masters and PhDs they have
backgrounds and everything from
aerospace engineering you know to you
know to civil engineering chemists to
you know doctors and what they are what
they are is they're available to work on
problems now to answer your question in
our style of innovation it's not about
managing the workforce we do that via
the model we engage in for the
enterprise so if the enterprise has been
able to identify effectively that it
needs a you know a new kind of a
material for a product it wants to take
the market and it's been unable to
develop that material what it will do is
it will work with innocentive or another
party and develop a what we call a
problem statement in that problem
statement is a well-defined need and
success criteria coupled with an
inducement call it a prize so for fifty
thousand dollars if anybody in the world
can solve this problem for me for fifty
thousand dollars I'll take that
intellectual property and and and gladly
pay you the prize now this is a really
important model because what it does is
it changes the question from how do you
manage a global workforce of smart
intelligent creative people to how do I
get everybody in the world who's capable
ready willing and able to work on this
kind of a problem you know going to work
on the problem for me and I really only
want to pay for success so this prize
based or inducement based model turns
out to be incredibly powerful